hello everyone it's time for Sundance
interview on behalf of the Kia Telluride
you are watching Collider we are
thrilled to be here and thrilled to be
here today with Jim Gaffigan thank you
so much and thank you for giving me the
SUV I guess I get one if I did the
interview right you got to talk to the
fine folks at Kia about that but uh
hopefully they'll hook you up give me
the phone number of mr. Kia
well the one thing I can't offer you
right now is a life water like that you
can have it that is just as good as an
SUV life water and good coffee you are
covered I'm excited and you need a lot
of coffee because you're very busy here
very very busy when I found out that I
was talking to you I was going through
everything you have here at Sundance but
also beyond just wondering like how is
your Sundance going so far have you
slept at all it's amazing yeah it's look
it's I mean I'm somebody who kind of
self describes myself as a lazy person
but there's there aren't those moments
of laziness as of late but yes Sundance
is amazing it's it's really exciting to
have these films here you know and you
know just came from a premiere and it's
you you forget how electric a premiere
is until you're in there because
otherwise you're like don't they just
didn't kids just watch like a an
animated movie in this theater or two
weeks ago but it is special it's a very
special thing a premiere but in
particular I feel like a Film Festival
and specifically a Sundance premiere
there there's something about not just
the interest of being here and to
explore new movies but it's almost like
a desperation or at least I feel it
where I need to be here and I need to
see everything I can well it's I I think
it's also the audience at a festival
there's an excitement and there's also
they're they're informed deer I mean
like they this is a film as a passion of
their so you better not have any clumsy
theatrical devices you're I mean
absolutely so to get into your three
films that
have here first up troop zero so at this
point in time
not many people out there gonna know
what these movies are so I am going to
force you to give me a brief synopsis so
that we can catch our viewers right also
first troop zero troop zero is the story
of a little girl played by me know a
little girl who in 1977 in southern
Georgia who is lives in a trailer park
community she aspires to she's
fascinated with outer space and she
aspires to get on this golden record
where they were gonna take this record
and have all these recordings and she
wanted to get on that golden record it
sounds complex but it's very accessible
and and so she forms a troupe to get you
know like a Girl Scout troop to get to
win this contest to be appearing on that
recording of the album and and there are
a troop of misfits and their de facto
leader is Viola Davis my daughter
McKenna Grace plays the she's the
spearheading of the whole thing and I
play a lawyer Mike Epps is in there were
a band of misfits surrounded by a group
of children that are misfits and Allison
Janney's in it and it's it's I haven't
seen it yet it's gonna be amazing though
but I think it's it deals a lot with
class and and people staying where
they're supposed to stay and so I think
it'll be fun to see I need to know about
working with McKenna grace because
there's actually like a little mini
McKenna grace fan club a Collider yeah
where I mean we just constantly talk
about her
well McKenna is the you know there is a
an almost maturity to her that is I've
got young children you know I've got
children
McKenna's age but McKenna has kind of
like a resourcefulness
and an understanding of how the world
works that is not normal and by the way
you know we're shooting in Louisiana in
May which means it's only a hundred and
twenty degrees that actually sounds
really appealing right now no but she
was a she was a trooper and it's
interesting because there's you know you
work with child actors and some of them
seem equipped for the task of acting in
films or on television shows and she's
definitely one of them she is something
else and another another I guess a pair
of people that I'm eager to hear about
how it was working with them on this
film is Burton Bertie because yeah when
I think about a list of directors that I
guess would be on my must watch list at
this point they're on it and I am just
dying to know what is it to you that
makes them stand out well I think Burton
Bertie are a very you know compelling
partnership you know I write a lot of
things with my wife and so I'm familiar
and I've done movies with other teams of
directors but Burton Bertie are a there
it's it's kind of reflected in just them
wearing hats like their ex they embrace
the eccentric they're fans of the
eccentric and there is a sweetness and
independence to each of them it's it's
very hard to articulate what's so
engaging about them because they create
a mystique when they're together but if
you met them individually they're
fantastic people but you know the power
of them together is greater than them
individually it sounds strange it sounds
like what would be required in a
directing team it's it's because I've
worked with other directing teams it's
it's also very interesting because they
all turn or alternate days of directing
but and that's not to say during
rehearsals they aren't doing it together
but there's a synergy there that is
because I you know I ran a show with my
wife it's like and this is the woman
married two and so that communication
even in the closest individuals is not
there but you know they'll communicate
with each other but there's a civility
you know one South African ones British
and there's like a civility that is
almost kind of strange but amazing
imagine something like that also has a
great effect not just on the ensemble in
the movie but it probably trickles down
to every single department yeah and well
the thing is is I saw that movie as it
was really hot I mean look at you know
hearing an actor complain about you know
what a shoot was like it's kind of
boring but the thing is is they were we
they're tough women that so they're
resilient they're going on fumes
it's unfazed eval and polite and calm
and as we know fish rots from the Hat
right and so they're they're a really
interesting group and they're also kind
of like this like force of light you're
mean like there's a lot of positive and
I think we need more of that
yeah on every movie definitely your next
one them that follow I'm fascinated by
this idea for a number of reasons but in
particular it's about snake handlers you
could probably add to that yeah is that
something that you read when it comes
your way and you're like I got to get
involved with that movie
yeah I mean well I think saying it's
about because it's weird cuz it's like
in them that follow I play father Olivia
Colman and I have a child who is not in
this community this devout community
that is you know interprets a line in
the Bible to believe that they should
work with snakes the it's not a
judgement of what I loved about what
Britain Dan did is that movie is not an
indictment of like these crazy
snake handlers it was just about this is
what these people believe in it's
authentic that they believe in them and
so you watch it and it's the movie ends
up being about this coming-of-age story
for for Thomas Mann and Alice and and
also Caitlyn and but what really it's so
like the snakes are yeah they're they're
an interesting element of the story but
it really has to do with I think about
parental relationships and also about
people coming into their own when
they're teenagers like what type of
person am I going to be am I gonna have
my father and my mother determine who I
am or am I gonna go out and see who I
want to be
sometimes when you jump into a movie
like that or at least when I watch a
movie like that where I can't
necessarily connect to the specific
things characters are doing but seeing a
different lifestyle well I don't know
reveal new truths about myself or
something like that did you have that at
all with the story and how they live
well I think with all these films that
are at Sundance there is you take away
something but specifically with them
that follow for me being the parent with
Olivia Colman of this son that is not
involved in their religious community
and then they feel guilt and it's I
guess my big takeaway was you know
parents have to deal with this strange
attachment that they have that they have
to let go and let their kids be who
they're gonna be so that was the big
takeaway there I mean in light from
light is I think it's a very I think
that light from light is a story about
damaged people can help other damaged
people and then troop zero is about you
know I play a dad who is imperfect but
you know through the movie he kind of
understands his limitations you know and
so it kind of forces you to take a look
at yourself jumping into light from late
a little everybody on collider knows
that I'm fascinated by the paranormal
and the investigations and everything so
first what is that movie about briefly
but also did you go in a believer did
anything you experienced while exploring
that story and those characters change
your feelings about that it's
interesting the paranormal thing for me
personally I'm I would say I'm a skeptic
but I'm not reluctant but reading the
script what Paul does so well and it's
also reflected in the film is again it's
not an indictment of these people it's
not you know the story isn't like these
ghost hunters are you know ripoff
artists or but and that's also really
reflected in Marin Ireland's performance
she's always good but like she's good
she's always good and so but so she adds
a certain vulnerability my character is
relatively reluctant but circumstances
force him to kind of embrace Maroons
character and kind of say hey I need
your help and so but you know it's what
I love about that movie is that if you
do like the paranormal you will be
fascinated by its treatment over because
it's not dismissive its questioning and
there's conversations where they're like
you know and they're sincere it's
authentic it's not stunty it's not but I
don't know I'm dying to see how an
audience responds because it's it's not
gonna be you know paranormal for and
it's not gonna be a documentary saying
this is all [ __ ]
so it's it like a lot of good films it
presents a lot of questions and it's
it's fleshed out characters that's what
I also loved was
the four main characters you really kind
of get to know them over the course of
the movie there's no broad strokes kind
of treatment you know scene by seeing
you learn a little bit more which is fun
place to show a movie like that I was
talking about it in a previous interview
just this idea of we play a game called
would you rather every once in a while
and I spent a couple questions to
pertain to film festivals and one of
them was would you rather go to a
festival with a crowd pleaser or a more
challenging film and just the thought of
the conversation that I've seen sparked
from certain movies that are premiered
already it's like how do you not go with
a bold daring move even though I don't
want to completely take away the value
of a good crowd-pleaser
yeah it is you know I've been to
Sundance before and there is the the
it's so amazing that the the premise of
Sundance which is kind of encouraging
people to like take these risks and and
tell these unique stories it's like what
a generous thing what a truly generous
thing in this commerce filled world that
we live in it's like no no we're
actually gonna reward people that don't
do the clumsy theatrical device and so
that's it's when you're here you're like
oh wow that's it's a really important
thing they're doing that is a big part
of the reason why I feel so grateful to
be here yeah and to be able to talk
about these movies and hopefully make a
difference for some of them yeah it's
great to see a movie that you're dying
to talk about afterwards yeah right
exactly and it's also it's a what's
great about Sundance is you watch a
movie and then you can discuss it
afterwards
but I feel like in this streaming age we
live in
like I'll watch something and I'll be
like I gotta find someone but I gotta
wake my wife up I don't know it's like
it's so it's it's really it's it's
there's something about Sundance that is
very special I mean obviously it's ego
wise it's great too but it's also that
let's indulge in the nerdier side of our
thoughts on it festival's almost
encourage face-to-face inter
action when you discuss because their
lines and the crowds and everything
we're streaming it's almost like it's
more of an instant an instant social
media conversation which is not you know
without its value but it's a very
different kind of an important human
interaction that you get to have here on
the ground standing in line meeting
complete strangers and being brought
together by film it's very fascinating
also to see the combination of we all
know that seeing a movie in a theater is
better we all know that there's an
excitement about a premiere but there's
also something at least you know there's
something about Sundance also it's like
a quarter of the audience film nerds
that are going to be unapologetic a
quarter of the audience is a cast and
crew of the film and and then you know
the the director sisters brothers you
know it's a very it's a very kind of
family like thing it's it feels almost
kind of like a an additional family
event dear I mean absolutely yeah it's
very personal and there's a you know
we're dealing with drama especially when
you're talking about filmmakers who jump
into a movie not just because it's
another job to take but who basically
give their lives to a movie for however
many weeks or months because then that
bleeds out to their whole family where
they become aware and invested and it's
important to be able to share that with
everyone yeah I picked up today we were
going to the premiere for them that
follow they picked me up and then they
went and I picked up dan who was one of
the directors with Britt of them that
follow and his family came out of the
condo to see him off to his film
premiere and it was the most adorable
thing and it was sincere and the dads
taking pictures and I was like yelling
out the window I'm proud of my son and
because I can't be but it was one of
those things where I mean I'm the
youngest of six kids and there are
moments when you're this creative person
going on this path where your family is
and your friends are
like you're crazy so when you can be
attendants and have that moment that Dan
had you're like yeah that's what it's
all about
it's you're passionate about anything
it's exciting you know it with family
absolutely when I was at New York
comic-con I got to bring my dad to one
interview I did and it's just that
moment I will never forget that moment
of him getting to see me in my element
and just take such great pride in that
it meant the world to me oh it means the
world to him I'm sure yeah definitely
did but we were talking a lot about the
theatrical experience but of course
streaming is a very important entity in
the industry right now and you are
jumping into something with Amazon which
is a big deal and very exciting so can
you tell me a little bit about coming to
the decision that we need to set this up
and get going well as you know you know
a comedian we look I've been doing
stand-up for close to thirty years when
I started there was there was no there
was Comedy Central in aversion there was
no satellite radio there was no YouTube
and HBO was pretty important but as
we've gone along stand-up specials have
you know first of all the entire
population is educated on stand-up
because they can access it on YouTube or
Netflix or Amazon now on Amazon and so
there is an educated population that
enjoy stand-up that loves it and so what
we've witnessed in the past couple years
has been a Netflix having a very steady
influence and really kind of dominating
where stand-up specials went because
they they could pay the these specials
could air without interruption and and
you know they're relatively inexpensive
to make and so as a performer and a
creator you know like other comedians we
were like when are these other streaming
Giants going to step forward and so I'm
thrilled that I'll have the first
special on
Amazon Prime and it's you know it's
amazing you know it's it's I mean some
of it is I've done specials in different
ways you know some on Netflix some on
Comedy Central I did one on my website
you know it's you you always like the
technology is always moving and like the
stranglehold that HBO held when I
started stand-up as the most important
destination is not true anymore and so
and Amazon I just you know they're I
mean like they bought a film yesterday
for an enormous so they have the
pocketbook they have an incredible
marketing team you know you can't go to
IMDB without seeing an Amazon ad for one
of their films which or one of their
shows which is great so as a comedian as
a creative person I like many people I
want people to see what I create and I
want to expand the audience that sees my
stuff and and so they were open they
approached me and it was it's an
incredible opportunity and it's really
interesting because it's in three years
you know it might be a different
conversation it's so true it's it's a
fascinating thing to watch as much as I
hold tight to the more traditional
viewing formats whether we're talking
about theater or traditional non binging
TV shows yeah it is kind of exciting to
see the wealth of original content that
we get now because there are so many
streaming services that are rising up
and embracing that rather than just
regurgitating things we've seen before
yeah it's it's I mean that's almost like
a separate conversation yeah because
it's there's a really you know the
zeitgeist moves very fast and there
shows that we were dying to see the
second season of that we haven't watched
the second season of that's one of my
nerd questions where you're like why
ever we watch that because there are so
many platforms and I would also say that
what I love about Amazon also is they're
you know I know that this is a
purposeful step in taking this special
this isn't kinda like we'll try it it's
like
they are very methodical and thoughtful
you know troop zero is an Amazon movie
they they make bold well-thought-out
steps that are supported so I'm I'm very
honored it is so encouraging to hear
that we have to wrap this up but before
I do I want to give every title and then
some a shadow so troop zero then that
follow light from light at Sundance this
year your Amazon specialist called
quality time and later this year you
also have American dreamer and being
Frank coming out plus a world stand-up
tour yes I hope you have a lot of
caffeine at your disposal I hope you get
some sleep along the way but I love it
it took me 30 years to get these
opportunities to complain about I'm
excited huge congratulations on thank
you so much for being here today guys
thank you so much for watching this
interview thanks for Kia Telluride to
make all this happen it is so greatly
appreciated like and share this video
we'll see you soon for more content from
Sundance 2019 where do I get my key
Italo ride let me let me get them to
pull that up for you
you